pour le moment les cherry on va revenir
sur france albanie samedi soir sur m6 il
y avait le match france albanie et c'est
ce qui a fait le plus parler énorme
d'arc a alors tout commence quand
l'hymne au delà de manille l'albanie est
jouée au stade de france
à ce moment là tout se passe bien et on
voit la tête des joueurs albanais ils
disent et intrigué l'appareil où je suis
pas mélomanes
il ya un problème regarder les hymnes
nationaux
là on commence par l'albanie
[Musique]
et denys jean marc il ya un problème un
problème de taille c'est qu'en fait line
qui a été jouée n'est pas l'hymne
albanais donc les albanais veulent que
leur vie ne soit joué avant d'accepter
de débuter le match donc pour l'instant
ça discute
c'est donc là les garants les voies
existent mais en fait c'est pas du tout
notre hymne alors personne ici n'avait
remarqué
on n'est pas spécialiste des hymnes et
donc forcément on savait pas moi un
moment quand j'ai vu ça j'ai appelé tout
de suite la chaîne et je leur ai dit est
ce que vous avez pris la régie du stade
de france
voilà c'est dit est ce que c'est la
régie du stade de france qui est puisque
non c'est un truc qu'on pourrait faire
donc à ce moment là on se dit que déjà
la situation est gênante
ouais mais c'est pas fini et on se dit
tout va rentrer dans l'ordre rapidement
mais non puisque c'était sans compter
sur le speaker du stade de france que je
kiffe vraiment je les adore cemac ce jeu
là dehors et il nous a offert c'est vrai
une boulette magistral mais c'est quand
même tout mais pas ça veut pas faut bien
le plan regarder la boulette bien
mesdames messieurs chers supporters
encore toutes nos excuses pour les
supporters de l'arménie voici donc lyn
de l'arménie s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
s'il vous plaît c'est bon quand ça va
pas ça va pas l'arménie sellal de donald
vanille merci donc à l'or donc c'est pas
l'arménie
c'est l'albanie mais bien entendu alors
on se dit bon ça va s'arrêter jusqu'ici
on résume mauvaise me lancer
le speaker s'est excusé envers le
mauvais pays donc si c'est libre ça y
est c'est fini
mais non ça continue parce que car la
question que tout le monde se pose
désormais c'est qu'elle il a été joué à
la place de l'hymne albanais donc allé
retrouver faut trouver un mec
spécialiste des hymnes donc c'est pas
évident donc sur m6 tu es à une
journaliste qui s'appelle carine galli
qui a voulu nous donner quelques
précisions
elle nous a révélé les origines de lyme
regardez voilà les arbitres qui ont
rappelé par ce coup de sifflet les
joueurs et a priori céline du monténégro
qu'on a entendu très bien qu'elle ait
une bonne info très bien carine bronard
fille sauf que c'est pas du tout eu du
monde électro selim ii d'andorre alors
c'est non mais c'est un truc de ouf
alors la fédération française de
football de l'équipe d'andorre s'est
moqué de cette gaffe sur twitter on vous
a manqué tant que ça équipe de france
qui calme mardi arrive très vite
est ce que ce sera mardi en dehors donc
ils prochaine des rallyes team devra
donc après plusieurs minutes de malaise
un miracle s'est produit puisque les
organisateurs ont enfin retrouvé
l'hymne de l'albanie qui a peut être
joué sur la tête vers ils ont dû taper
sur youtube c'est obligé pour faire là
c'était panique à bord trouve moi les
mno de l'albanie bordel de merde c'est
pas compliqué regardez
[Musique]
allez jouer et alors ça a été un
déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya un internaute a posté un tweet qui
m'a bien fait rigoler si regardez quand
monsieur hanouna à son pass vip au stade
de france et que tu lui laisses les
commandes voilà donc ce qui crée dit il
ya regardez la vidéo qu'il a partagée
dans son tweet c'est une grosse d'arc à
regarder
[Musique]
à
alors alors tout le monde s'est excusé
didier deschamps a réagi à la polémique
et a tenu à s'excuser c'était sur rtl
voilà dans la radio d'isabelle
morini-bosc regarder oui ça me gêne je
me suis excusé je m'en excuse encore
auprès du peuple albanais après en
maîtrise pas tout mais c'est arrivé mais
ça doit pas ça doit pas arriver après
c'est toujours ce que l'on attendait
d'eux les autres on doit se le dire
aussi pour nous mêmes c'est à dire le
respect pour eux c'est un mac un manque
de
de respect voilà c'est en quoi comme on
dit il faut toujours se mettre à la
place des autres et d'avoir ce sentiment
de ne pas être respectés c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien j'aime bien didier il ya
des gens qui a remis les crampons ce
matin qui jouent ils jouent bien le lit
et les mêmes les joueurs français ont
également réagi en conférence de presse
suisse à la suite à un incident en garde
et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une grosse
heure donc voilà leur demander pardon
c'est
grosse faute quand même été une erreur
et voilà c'est pour la sait pas c'est
pas terrible on va dire et c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de tweets sur tpm
pays il ya à lolo qui a dit de l'as que
ce soit cyril hanouna qui annonce que
c'était lui qui a tout mis en place pour
sa prochaine grande race rare il ya
maxime qui lui france albanie - bonne
organisation qu'une émission dan hanouna
je suis mort de tweets on a retrouvé le
boulet du 14 juillet au stade de france
le mec qui a préparé les hymnes avant le
match il est comme ça en ce moment
regarder ça c'est un tweet de quentin
regardez le mec comme ailier le mec qui
a préparé les in avant le match nice en
train de retrouver le gars est chez nous
voila voila merci comment réparer y
voilà et on a un ptdr donc là après
avoir passé l'hymne du monténégro le
speaker annonce qu'on va rejouer l'hymne
pour l'arménie tout ça contre l'albanie
impossible n'est pas français ça c'était
énorme ce qui s'est passé vraiment
c'était très drôle mais après tout il
n'ya pas eu il ya pas besoin de se
confondent en est ce que c'est juste une
boulette les joueurs albanais aurait pu
se marie en disant qu'est ce que c'est
que cette chanson c'est pas la nôtre
hystérie ni c'est pas un incident
diplomatique non plus c'est le mec s'est
trompé dans la musique
séverine la mairie sion c'est pas une
agression du bassiste ont sucé
c'est sûr il va pas voir une guerre et
la france à propos de guerre il ya
quelques années il ya eu un truc que moi
je trouvais pire que ça l'année dit il
sans doute les états unis et l'allemagne
l'allemagne a gagné et ce qui a retenti
dans le stade au moment de la
reconnaissance de lyme c'est l'hymne
nazi dallas a fait un vrai vrai je
trouve si j'ai une soirée je vous
appellerai très bonne ambiance ça craint
vraiment alors si tu sais vous allez je
vais redire l'elysée tout ça